die leute noch ganz kurz vorweg bevor
das wieder anfängt ich bin an diesem
samstag also samstag den zehnten sekten
in augsburg auf der dult messe auf der
salzburger messe in der halle 6
anzutreffen von 12 ist jetzt nur bücher
und ab 14 uhr ein paar coole fotos und
autogramme und so weiter machen sinn
kommt auf jeden fall vorbei wenn ihr in
der umgebung wohnen ich freue mich
wir sind uns willkommen beim ein video
was geht ich hoffe euch geht es gut mir
geht auch wundervoll ich hab schön
ausgeschlafen hatte die letzten zwei
tage nicht so viel schlafen ich euch das
jetzige erzähle auf jeden fall ist mir
heute morgen aufgefallen
ich habe ja wirklich schon echt lange
kein junges mädchen video mehr gemacht
fand ich sehr traurig auch extrem mit
genau umgekehrt hier monatlich noch
ändern könnt kam von mir diese videos
zehn mädchen trends zehn jungs trends
die ich immer von euch zu bewerten
lassen hat und darüber behalten wie das
macht also zum beispiel zehn mädchen
fans jungs hatten oder zehn jungs trends
die mädchen liebt das gibt halt genau
das weiß auch der vierte fahrt sehr
gefehlt hat und zwar zehn jungs trennt
die mädchen lieben mädchen mögen mädchen
teufel mädchen ab ricky simms was immer
ich hab euch nämlich wieder auf setzte
gefragt und finster könnte mir gerne
folgen wenn es doch nicht tut was ihr so
also vor allem ist die mädchen was ja an
jungs mögt was sollen jungs tragen was
gefällt euch und das wollen wir uns
jetzt mal zusammen an was ihr mir da so
geschickt habt und gehen bis sind darauf
ein wie gesagt ist eure meinung ist
nicht meine und mal gucken ich bin
gespannt und ich hab gehört weiß 15.000
likes gibt es könnte ja meinen kommentar
schwestern kommt was ist gut doch vorweg
sagen möchte ich hab natürlich schon ein
paar angeschaut und es war vieles dabei
wo ich dachte okay krass das sehe ich es
nicht wirklich so aber wir gehen es
jetzt einfach mal durch meinen spieler
kein mädchen und ihr könnt ja mal
analysieren oder es war ja auch die
aufgabe von meinen snapshot voller was
zu tun ist klar die extra früher haben
die jungs immer hosen getragen die unten
weiter geschnitten sind jetzt fragen
viele jungs die in jeans was ich
persönlich besser findet weiß nicht
genau ist ein trend das aber egal
natürliches und rennt also als frau mary
zu sein ich hatte früher so mit 13 oder
14 hatte ich auch nur weiter hose aber
jetzt habe ich nur noch etwas andere
wurden auf keinen fall diese ganzen die
finde ich dann schon
gefällt mir halt persönlichen butler auf
leute ich hab die lehre zu jedem punkt
wäre ich jetzt einfach das anziehen was
er da geschrieben habt und dann schauen
wir mal wie ich am ende aussieht und
dann könnte ja meine kommentare
schreiben
ob ich euch gefallen oder halt nicht so
vom style herr trend da also dann fangen
wir mal an mit einer mini die nur nach
einer kleinen auseinandersetzung mit
mein mitbewohner der meinte gini dass
jetzt keine skinny jeans das ist einfach
eine rose die etwas enger ließ jetzt
nicht mega eng aber ich dachte ein schon
das ist justine jeans wenn nicht ist mir
egal ob ich jetzt vermahlen machen wir
weiter der nächste punkt kommt von
zilien das habe ich auch mega oft lesen
und zwar geschmackssache aber ich war
natürlich geschmackssache ist immer aber
ich weiß dass viele mädchen mit
ausschnitt eines jungen mögen wenn er
long short und einen pulli oder so trägt
ich weiß dass du vor einem halben jahr
oder so immer diese jungs dieses t shirt
bis zum boden hatten also bis zum boden
zu langen aber so ein ganz bisschen
länger ist finde ich also das reicht
mittlerweile auch schon relativ oft so
wartet man also das geht hier bislang
das ist mir eigentlich schon zulagen
werde dir gleich aussehen
aber ob ich jetzt einfach mal gesucht
wird der nächste snap kommen von dieser
hübschen name und zwar schreibt sie das
habe ich auch wirklich aufgelesen und
viele handeln hektisch wie zum beispiel
eisen sich sagen ja viele dass es zu
feminin sag ich jetzt mal aber rosa
pulli es richtig heftig bei jungs und um
ernst zu sein heißt das war jetzt nicht
oft aber ich habe ja auch ein rosa pulli
auf der welt projekte moment
und ich aber noch ganz gelesen das sieht
am coolsten aus oder das feiert die
meisten männer so ein bisschen größer
als ein bisschen august und der auf
jeden fall relativ groß kann man sich
darüber streiten ob das mit dem t shirt
passt arbeit sozusagen jetzt aber sonst
würde ich jetzt niemals rausgehen weil
das ist mir das schon viel zu heftig
aber egal wir machen wir weiter wenn
sich jungen ausspielen und denken sie
können jede haben ließ grüßen mich und
das ist wirklich auf diesen snap bezogen
wo ich gesagt habe wir doch mal sachen
dir an jungs trends feiert auch das was
falsch ist an oder wenn nicht okay würde
jetzt das gegenteil behaupten aber gut
das ganze wasser kurz ins netz also ich
hab diesen filter benutzt der monster
groß ist und wo man gleichzeitig
aussieht als wenn man zehn jahre jünger
und marini schreibt also diesem feld das
wir mal nicht aber ist natürlich auch
könig dia trend habe ich mich auch
gefragt
viele also ich persönlich ich weiß nicht
ob ich das falsch verstanden habe aber
einen trend aber als trennt sich schon
so an was viele jungs tragen also an
sicherheit auf den style bezogen nicht
auf das verhalten
das ist für mich dann kein trend mehr
deswegen ich hoffe ich finde sich der
einzige das so versteht ich habe jetzt
den nächsten zwölf ausgesucht und zwar
ein trend den wir lieben sind vom backen
und das habe auch echt richtig viele
geschickt finde ich irgendwie mega cool
weil ist ja klar so ich hab voll viele
brücken und ich war eigentlich noch beim
marken- und könig ob vielleicht dürfen
wir aber ich finde eine geile akte ist
eigentlich ein wichtiger als kleine
schuhe flog diese jacke hatte ich
wirklich vorher noch nie als er sich für
die hatte ich vorher noch nie an keine
ahnung ob die hierzu passt aber wir
probieren es einfach mal so wir machen
weiter eigentlich ist es gar nicht vor
allem steht so im winter sich so oft
jungs herum laufenden halten und diese
hosen hochgekrempelt haben und ich denke
mir alter ist ziemlich kite an den
knöchel in die christina zeigt auf jeden
fall wenn jungs und die rote umkrempeln
und man die kirche sieht möchte auch mal
machen und was du für dich niemals
ausgehen was ich jetzt noch gefunden
habe alles mika außer rote hast du
gehört werden aber gesagt wurde schüler
also alles nicht außer rote würde ich
sagen wir einfach mal weiter an sondern
ist mein outfit eigentlich komplett also
habe ich es auch an und noch kurz ein
etwas wirklich gerade gefunden habe alex
ich finde es toll wenn new mid cap
tragen ich liebe kämpft über alles und
sie stehen fast jedem jungs an teams
zählt auch noch eine kerb auch
wir machen jetzt noch ein auto check
also das outfit ein bisschen verfilmten
uns noch kurz heißt also 3 2 1 let's go
[Musik]
ich glaube die socken ausziehen oder
sind das nicht fressen meinst du gar
nicht jetzt auch mythos vizekusen
entwickelt designer der in der leiste
ich mir fertig sein
eine bomberjacke find ich cool also die
meisten sachen finde ich cool aber du
warst finde ich absolut uncool
auch letzte und langscheid darunter
wasser riecht darunter sucht verstärkung
ist jetzt nicht also nicht so mein
geschmack aber natürlich eben dass sein
ich kann mich ja noch mal kurz drehen
bitte nicht lachen treppe einfach meine
kommentare ob ihr das jetzt cool findet
oder nicht vom outfit her würde ich so
ein beuteschema entsprechen also an die
mädels jetzt oder er überhaupt nicht
interessiert hier könnt ihr besonders
gerne von einem system machen ansonsten
das gerne nach oben da ist ihm
kommentare was noch zu sehen wollt
selbst und instagram weil es ein gewinn
ist es ab und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder haut rein